I will be showing you the game from a
Chicago pond tournament and against
grandmas and Nicola Setlock and this
will be the first time we are doing a
YouTube premiere which is like a live
chat so make sure you tune in to watch
this so this game is clearly 2010
Chicago Open is one of the biggest open
tournaments in US probably the second
biggest I mean world open its little bit
bigger but it's very strong tournaments
so my opponent is a strong Grandmaster
from Serbia so I play d4 Knight f6 c4 g6
at the moment do we know the opening or
not yet we know which opening is this
close but we have to wait for one more
move ok one more move and then we would
know exactly which opening is this
because it could be Kings Indian yes
like let's say if you plays Bishop g7
that's Kings Indian defense but my
opponent played that's why we don't know
it's unknown at the moment but you will
see but after we play the move actually
played Kings India but he quickly
transpose it to do d5 and this is now
Grunfeld defense ok see I could have
played efore here stop him from the
groom felt see if I play for that's it
there is no going back now no more groom
fell for him it's very unusual for a
groom field players to play King's
Indian and not often you see players
that play the ball because they're two
completely different openings the King's
Indian a group but here my opponent
shows that he basically he's ready to
play King's Indian but in this move
order he is also happy to play the groom
felt defense so many different ways
white can play against this opening but
it's a very very tough opening to crack
so
you can try many different lines here
you can play Bishop before Bishop g5 III
even played but that Queen b3 is very
sharp lines but I went for the classical
taking on d5 this is the very main main
line takes takes c5 from the first
glance it looks like it should be really
good for white because white has the
control of the center and the pawns are
controlling many many squares but on the
other hand black has a pressure on d4 so
he has a good contra play putting
pressure on d4 with 96 Castle Bishop g4
so this is kind of what he wants to do
ensue castle
96 Bishop g4 and put lots of pressure
along with this diagonal so the bishop
on Bishop on g7 is a very good piece
okay so White has a couple of options
here he can play he can play a look be
one but there would be one here one of
the main lines or you can play the move
Bishop to e3
so I play Bishop III protecting the d4
pawn so now if he takes on before I can
take back with a pawn
so the idea is to try to protect the
center now we pay queen a5 attacking the
panel c3 at the same time threat is to
take on before the threat is to take on
d4 and I cannot capture back to this
palm because our pin so I really have to
play this move if I want to capture back
with a pawn so let's see if we can find
my next move here which more do you
think I played here
we want to clean the to another idea is
Bishop d2 as well here I can also play
Bishop d2 but it doesn't feel right to
go Bishop b3 and then go back to should
be killed normally in the opening you
don't want to do that you don't want to
move the same piece more than what more
than once and plus I want to develop a
piece that is not developed which is my
Quinn so these are going back it's not
really in opening you should try to
avoid doing that if you can moving the
same piece more than once and to play
retreating moves so the bishop is
already only three but you go back
that's like you retreat retreat so
that's why go Queen d2 now he castles
now Brooke c1 this is the important move
here
Brooke is always very vulnerable on this
line and it's always hanging and that's
why I want to play the move
Brooke see one to protect on c3 and at
the right moment I can play also the
move d5 now because I already protected
my c3 pawn early earlier I can never I
can never play this move because let's
say go share what's at play this move
there should be three if I want to chase
the bishop I will lose the pawn on c3 in
my claim so normally when you have a
center you want to try to advance the
center because more you advance you
enter to his territory so you're gonna
control more squares so Roxy one look at
the eight plate now putting pressure
again and this is a typical way of
playing the groom self defense that you
develop pieces you put pressure and you
bring them to attack on d4 now I have to
make a decision here
because he is already threatening to
take exchange Queens so I really have to
do something here
what are my options besides just playing
let's say Bishop b2 that will allow the
character is there anything else I can
try to do here
d5 yes it's a very strong I would say
principle of principled move if you want
to have an advantage you have to play
this move d5 otherwise you probably end
up in an equal position if you play
Bishop b2 so this is very principled
move d5 and now the idea is to play c4
and strengthen the center so I really
want to play this move next and of
course he will play a six so this is
normal you know once you start advancing
black will try to attack the center now
I played this should be too because my
King is stuck in the middle of the board
so I want to develop the bishop and
castle so I can have the safety for my
king
I don't want to keep my king in the
middle of the board so it's very
important for you to do the same to when
you feel like you're behind and develop
and you want to get the pieces out and
cancel so that's why you play Bishop e2
and Castle
takes
so I have to take back and Bishop g4
they should be for activating the bishop
and putting pressure on f3 c4
my idea is to strengthen my d5 pawn and
if my opponent takes I can capture back
in fact I have options here I can
capture back with the king with the
bishop with a knight probably with the
knight Bishop b2 King e2 and an endgame
like this is actually quite unpleasant
for black because I have a strong past
pawn and my king is well placed in the
middle of the board in the end games you
want your King actually to be in the
middle that will be closer to go to the
both sides of the board so if it's on
one side if I have I wouldn't want to
castle here because then I'm too far
away from my pawns here so in the
endgame when they're not so many pieces
on the board especially the Queen's are
off the board it's okay it's okay to
have the King in the middle so he plays
so you don't want to go into this
because he's just slightly worse play
the move Queen a tree trying to keep the
Queen's on the board and the Queen is on
an active Square definitely putting
pressure on my weak pollen III and also
he's controlling this toothbrush
now what do you think I should play here
it's time it's time to play which month
could maybe play Bishop g5 who maybe
played Bishop g5 attacking the rook
five
so we should do for say Rocky
the night goes to d7 not sure I think
his rook is actually at the moment Luke
on the eighth it's not very effective
because he's just attacking this palm
but this pawn is protected so I can
never take but I think now he we play
Bishop g5 now suddenly is an open file
so I'm not sure if this helps us to get
much advantage so the pawn on c5 is
protected by the Queen so you cannot
take right now let's all take back so
any other suggestions counselor yeah of
course Castle this is a move that you
don't want to hesitate you know you
don't want to keep the King in the
middle again many many bad things can
happen if your king is stuck in the
middle of the board you could be in big
trouble and lose the game so safety of
the King is always the number one
priority when you play chess it's much
more important than winning some
material because now the king is safe
the rooks are connected now you have a
really good game now if they try to say
look at that fancy move ninety six and
we cannot capture because of the pin the
pin and white white will be losing the
Queen here
okay so black is developing his night
and now he's threatening to enter South
the central squares let's say on d4 so
of course you can play like 97 as well
here but 96 it just looks better now
what to do here
decision to make a decision here
c3 Bishop takes h3 we could play HD I
just kind of anticipate that he will
take on f3 next and it will plant the
knight on if before this is what he
wants to do he wants to take I take back
then he wants to go 94 this is what he
wants to do okay this is what he really
really wants to do
a ch3 it's a good move but I think
that's gonna happen anyway so I don't
think I want to waste but it's you know
I have a more useful move for this
position so I'm going deeper I'm already
anticipating sort of watches before it's
gonna happen here so I want to have my
pieces lined up the best way when he
starts taking on f3 and playing the 94
so I'm trying to be two three steps
ahead here in anticipation of that line
because I don't think he has other good
ideas here except taking and putting the
knight on d4 definitely a candidate move
h3 to be one you could play this move
but let's say he just plays b6 just
tumble them to give us the pawn yeah you
know just strengthen the position
you should see five now
that's a rope do sir
but these six you know it's big big big
commitment every six because these six
use you know step away from your part
chain and you're no longer going to be
protected
you no longer going to be that securely
protected anymore okay so this is little
bit dangerous
Brook fd1 very close there you go yeah
you know why because the e-file is the
open file right right and we know that
rooks belong where open file right so I
would put it on the 8th if I'm gonna be
able to push it but here I know that
he's gonna start shaking so it's a very
it's not an easy move to make Luke ft-1
is a very natural move as well but here
I I know that he's gonna maybe take on
f3 now and I want to have that
opportunity to have a rock there and he
took it doesn't have too many other
moves here because this rook is already
developed and this rook is not yeah but
the stroke is still doing some
protection here covers certain squares
in fact if you go here you actually
might get into a little bit of trouble
with this month because you left that
square and now he's got this idea this
is called what we call this in chess
skewer right excellent
so again this kind of positions where
it's very very close every move is
important you can't just play any move
you have to you very quickly lose any of
the advantage if you have any so here
it's very like very very close to
boredom lining up like a black hasn't
done anything bad yet so I mean so it's
very important to play the most precise
moves so he didn't say anything better
then he went for that line I don't know
do you guys see maybe anything else
black could have done he took it he took
and one night before you see maybe
another some other ideas some
alternatives no the night I can take the
night now
that drug has to stay here to pin rook
has to stay to pin that's why I mean for
example 95i looks like a normal of 94 by
the way you see why night before losses
or it's bad yeah take the pawn now this
is hanging winning this if he goes 95
now you can take now if you take with
the bishop you're dropping the bishop on
g4 so he has to take here and now look
at that are attacking this
it takes
take the bishop up upon if he doesn't
take it moves the bishop much better
take the rook little tactic what kind of
tactic is Knight f7 what is the name for
that tactic
Intermezzo right in inter measuring
between move yeah before you know you
capture you insert in between move and
then you went material always look for
this ideas you'll be surprised how often
even grandmasters they miss this kind of
in between moves it happens all the time
like a little ideas because here it
changes the evaluation with Knight f7
white is nearly winning without that
it's just better position so not easy as
you can see not easy to to move so he
went for the critical line before okay
95 looks natural but again this kind of
move is just looks good for one move
then you simply drop the Bishop back and
then it's unclear what is the knight
doing here because all the squares then
I can go to are simply cut off by this
Bishop so remember if the knight is only
five this Bishop 22 is doing a great job
cutting off the squares then I can go to
so this Knight actually really belongs
on this succession but I don't see it a
route you know that he can get here
anytime soon so this is a clear clear
advantage for white in this position as
well
so
you play 94 and big moment in a game big
moment
big decision needs to be made here what
to do with this night leave it there or
take it again by taking the night that's
a big big decision because you're giving
up your bishops the pair of the bishops
remember it's always important to have
their pair of the bishop and it's a most
of the time it's considered an advantage
to have the pair of the bishops only in
very rare positions where it's
completely locked up the bishops cannot
maneuver as well as the knight but in
general two bishops versus Bishop and
Knight is considered an advantage most
of the time and here is no exception
so the question but he has a threat
there he wants to take the bishop so you
have to either move that bishop or part
away with your dark square bishop
take your time little bit try to
calculate get into the position so you
can decide what the best move here is
it's always tricky when you have you
know decisions you know like here keep
the bishop take that night
okay let's see who is ready
yes
it's wonderful
yes well tonight is the square is
covered for now but the night is causing
a serious trouble here just immediately
13 potato light square bishop and the
only way to keep the bishop is I don't
know to play Bishop before I guess I
wasn't so sure I thought you know it's
just too much too much movement with the
same piece you know and now again I put
this Bishop here but what is it
billionaire I mean it's kind of biting
the ground here it's not much gonna
happen here so bad place 96 rookie 7
doubles the rooks it's pretty compacted
so the other alternative is not much
better to play Bishop d1 so I took away
my bishop but I knew exactly what I want
to do here so black has two options you
can take back with the bishop or he can
take back with the pawn my opponent took
back with a pawn which may seem it's
strange considering that he can take
that with the bishop and have a nice
Bishop but if it is the bishop I think
I'm keeping a small place here after a
very important move
very important move if I don't have this
move I have nothing here rook is seven
and now have a rope on a seventh rank
attacking the pawn here he goes here and
look at that how quickly I'm ENGLISH
gaining some initiative here
and then I have these six we should be
five coming in and now we go back to see
the moment where I played this move rook
fe1 see if I had played h3 he would have
taken we got the same position but he
died out of upon h3 instead of the
option imagining we would get the same
position he would for sure take back
with the bishop and I don't have rookie
7 here so that's why he took back at the
pawn because he didn't want to allow my
rook to go to e7 because now his queen
is kind of part of the game and covering
the e7 square again very important move
needs to be played here for white
otherwise no advantage
you have to play c5 because otherwise he
will put the Queen on c5 he will
blockade this pawn that this pawns are
never gonna go anywhere so this move c5
is absolutely important to play now I
have these two nice pawns in the center
ok the c5 pawn is gonna be attacked
immediately because otherwise I was
gonna maybe consider playing D 5 D 5
Bishop takes b7 Bishop was to d5 so it
plays here
now attacking the pawn on c5 now what to
do c6 yes
thanks take with what correct
d 3 he says you know your pawn isn't
your past pound is on a third rank I'm
gonna get my own I'm gonna get my own a
third rank let's try to understand what
is the major difference between whites
and black position here cuz it seems
very similar I have a pawn on a third
rank you know he's got a passed pawn
we both have passed pawns on a third one
but there is a major difference here
well his pawn is protected twice as well
but the way that my pawn is protected he
can never take it because he can never
take this because I'll take the rock but
his pawn is not protected by a bishop so
this pawn is little bit vulnerable okay
maybe one herbal here so what to do here
you should to e4 that's a move but the
way I was visioning to win this game is
somehow to be able to push this pawn
push it to c7 and play Bishop b7 and
move this rock and queen that's what I'm
thinking but I cannot play this right
away because if I play this right away
it gets this now he wants to take my
pawn so I can't just do it right away so
I go here rook II D 1 now bringing more
pressure to the d3 pawn and now my Queen
can move somewhere here I can never move
my queen because although this d2 threat
see if I do something like this big
problem my both rooks getting fork so
that's why I cannot do that so I play
this move for that purpose just put it a
more stable square and to put pressure
on the d3 pawn okay
now he goes Bishop e5 he's covering the
c7 square so I cannot push that palm
that's now he can just take it should I
do now
chitra
it's a very important move that gives me
a lift
escape square for my King and also
restricts the diagonal of the bishop
takes away the f4 square at some point
he could play Bishop f4 and attack my
role so this is a multi-purpose move an
excellent preventing move okay now I get
my escape square for my King so it's
it's good now he goes 26 again his
problem is that pawn that pawn on d3 is
vulnerable okay but if we take the rooks
after board here for example then I
cannot win this position so it's
important I rocks are on the board here
so I'm taking G to various moment useful
useful move most of the King away from
the background so there are no checks
there's no some diagonal checks and at
the same time protect the bishop now I
goes Queen f6 see this ship is protected
now otherwise he would go there and
start attacking
now what should I do
excellent queen a5 activating the queen
and attacking the pawn and at the same
time keeping an eye on this square
remember we always want to play c7 when
we can to play Bishop d7 that's how we
gonna try to win this game h5 he says
you know I'm gonna push and create come
to play now let's stop it first let's
not let him get you know let's not get
him let him get that activity okay we
don't want to allow h4 h 3 then we have
to worry about tactics we don't need
that just go there calmly prevent his
advance he was in g7 now he says ok my
king is very safe - would you would you
have here
Brooksie for crooks afford taking it
upon taking pawn is a possibility but ok
keep in mind here okay it okay to as
well so you might be kind of I believe
the backfiring call because the rock is
gonna be on a second right what I'm
trying to do here is I put my rook on a
fourth rank so he can never play the D
to move with the tempo and I'm trying to
see if I can somehow surrender and win
this pawn this is my plan
rookies well placed here can go to a
fork and go to e4 and it's not gonna be
hanging rook t6 plate
Queen b5 I play first panco c70 got to
be very careful because now he'll just
drop back and I say one two three three
attackers on me and I cannot just I
cannot just play they move like look
here because he can push the deep on
this Bishop g4 tapes that pawn is very
important yeah that's why he played an
h-file actually he anticipated that
happening so that's fine he played h5 so
ok so I played the move b5 this allows
me to play how much play Queen b7 and
now I'm putting an eye on this move on
this d3 pawn I really want to get that D
triple he wants Queen in fact he was
getting a living in time trouble so now
I was just trying to make moves that it
going to be kind of annoying for him to
deal with when opponent is getting a
long time you make moves that are more
annoying more difficult to respond
against okay they might not be known
necessarily the strongest Mouse but the
moves that will create problems yeah so
it's it's an interesting idea to do so
now that queen is look looks a little
bit awkward
not only five what can you do now
doesn't feel right that last move
doesn't feel very right here
see
absolutely Roxy five look at that pee
now vertical pin yeah
now he's getting more uncomfortable he
doesn't want to play of 6f6 really
weakens the position you know the
seventh rank and everything so now he
goes to be eight clever tactic he's
trying to use tactics to change the
outcome here you know of course should
ask first of all why can't I just take
do you see why he cannot take why I
cannot take
it's trying to complicate a position
which is so which is the right thing to
do when you're in trouble you're losing
you got to keep it complicated but my
question to you is why can't I just take
the brook what's the hidden trick you
know that he has f6 correct I'm just a
Poirot can I please rook f6 and now he
has pressure here and my queen is under
attack it's a big trouble because when I
dropped this I dropped the rook as well
here so I'm dropping dropping a lot of
things here okay there was some computer
moved up D 320 is d3 Queen b3 back but
to be honest with you I'm not too
certain if I can win this position much
better much better but I'm not sure if
it's just like totally winning
okay look well but that gives you a rook
my master gives you rook he he's got
something you know so you just got to
make sure you don't just you know
immediately take you pause you think now
I need a good square for my Queen stable
square
Queen c4
now everything is guarded I'm ready to
push c7 and I'm keeping a close eye on
the tree not to mention the move Bishop
d3 I have he plays d2
he plays d2
c7 he pushes we push it right we gotta
respond
hey go succeed
they should be sir very important to
play this move because otherwise once it
plays rook d7 you're gonna lose this
pawn you lose this pawn you got
absolutely nothing the only thing is
this pawn so Bishop c7 now I'm attacking
the rook again again he's counting on
some tactics
look at that move he's counting on
tactics that they're gonna help him and
he plays the move in a time trouble
thinking okay he's gonna have some
checks if I take the rook he's gonna
have some checks some bishops sacrifice
ideas or it actually takes so I cannot
take the rock but now what does he what
do you see in his position here do you
see something called overworked piece
it's a very common thing right
overworked piece happens in almost every
game yeah when one piece is doing more
than more than one thing multiple things
and eventually that pieces just become
overloaded
Queen Queen is overloaded it's guarding
the bishop its guarding the rook if you
can think that way then it's gonna be
very easy to see the next move that I
play because my idea is simple deflect
the Queen how you get at that
look to e5 that's either only five look
at that just take it now he takes it and
then after this upper piece
he takes let's go back home safe and
solid and he resigned because he's done
a fool piece down a fool Bishop not even
a pawn to show for it
you understand he cracked the tenth
obviously I mean position was already
difficult this was this is really a
difficult position but I think he
started to play really awkward this
Queen e5 so so that's one of the best
things for him here would have been to
actually forget about this pawn and try
to get a bishop on b6 and try to get
some kind of blockade boy that's
probably the best way he could have
tried to played this position yeah I
don't think I like this whole rook lifts
ideas perhaps he can try to play this
this should be for says you know what
I'm just gonna give that font but we
should be six and
it's very hard to win a position like
this I have a bond but I can say here he
just goes fish yeah it's gonna take a
lot of efforts to to move that Bishop
from there and the presence of opposite
color bishops gives more drawing chances
got it
excellent now
now we will do a couple of medium
difficulty positions and see if how well
you do this maybe we'll do one on
difficult - um - okay so this was my
game from that tournament okay that I
want so let's move on now to their
tactics I'll say after position give you
a couple of minutes to try to find the
way to win white to play and win here
let's see if we can find a plan
and this again between two grandmasters
okay to Grand Master's are playing this
game
white is down exchange and if it doesn't
do anything quickly enough you you lose
the game
yes in the back
Bishop g5 excellent move yes Bishop g5
and what is the idea yep so look this
emblem is my only move to try to defend
this and now do you see the regrouping
idea you just regroup the pieces you
just swap them in you're just gonna swap
your pieces and then it's gonna be a
game over six check
you have six and with unstoppable mate
on a chain do you see what just happened
the original position swap the pieces
Queen goes on a six Bishop on f6 that's
your mating net on h8 h8 square remember
it is one of the most difficult squares
to protect this is very difficult to
protect because to protect that you need
like a knight the rook or you know it's
it's very difficult that's all you know
you just swap them and then now it's
just meaning can do able to do anything
actually okay nice work
yeah thought this would be a fun one for
you to do because it's it's not that
obvious actually this idea again from
practical point of view I'll tell you if
this was a quick in mean a lot of lot of
grandmasters might might not be able to
see it so quickly yeah lots of time to
think and you're kind of feeling the
position you know what's what you should
be doing yeah you probably find it but
it's not it's not just out there to see
it quickly so very nice moving forward
position number two white to play and
win this is a game of a remastered gotta
come ski was a u.s. champion
I think four times so what to do here
fight to play and win
why to play and win make sure a position
is correct the opposition is correctly
did 20 2016 this idea
okay you got the first idea but I need
you to go deeper because it's not so
easy to just okay
yeah palm push there is a there is idea
Bishop f8 there and it protects g7 and
hits the quail
very quickly
of course the first thing you should be
looking at rook f7 because that opens up
the position
haha King takes f7 okay there are two
moves in that position he can go King e8
he can go King e6
can you see a little bit more or should
we put the mouse in yes
aha that's what he's saying yeah King
takes pawn push I'm not sure just take
that all right we're on the right track
let's just put the moves in now I'll
make it a little easier takes 96 okay
six there's some kind of defense
okay it's probably still good for you
after 25 points we have seven
capture the Quinn captures your point
and then we don't exchange at the end at
the end with down exchange
okay let's go back this doesn't work so
well I think we have this line right so
we got to this point and my question was
I can go to I can go to eat and can go
to here so first of all if I go to here
let's do this one it's easier
what is the move goes here
f5 works there
you just choose this way to make exposed
King two pairs two pair a pair of
bishops and a strong pawn on e5 this is
not gonna work out well good luck
so that's mate and if he goes to qing-ge
eight
yeah this should be far is probably
winning yeah there should be five King
f8 they were lacking a faith
clean seasick check now if it goes here
then we had the Bishop b5 check the King
goes back we have the Queen e8 mate and
if it goes here then I think we can go
check
check
don't take yet check
check
check
I better clean up here huh take
everything so so you have to play the
only move King f8 and now you want to
push it to the light square because then
you have your Bishop coming in you want
the King on the light squares because
you have a light square bishop yeah six
because here then Bishop g6 comes in a
six consent so he went here
nice
if he goes here look at that mate check
the strength yeah strength of the
position now he went here
I actually hear it's very bad it's me
so you went here he's like can you take
my quit at least you know you don't even
want to do that yet
check first he goes away we kick so he
has to go here oh we have another Bishop
here right look at that check and you
designed finally because it's too much
because here so many ways to win here
but let's just finish it this way check
check
checkmate
got it so ability ability to attack come
tsuki had come ski had no problem
finding this in a real game again the
difference when we're doing it here when
I set it up you already know there is
something there but when we are playing
these games right now masters we're
playing this it's you don't know
sometimes the tactics they don't work
you have to spend a lot of time
calculating and trying to understand
whether or not it's gonna work out so
that's the difference
right and let's do one fun study okay
studies where it's actually it's not a
game but it's just composed okay this
this is composed if you a few few of the
students here might be familiar with
this maybe I showed before but really a
lot of fun this study here white to play
and win how to win this position the
other night it looks like you're so
close to checkmate you know but it's not
it's not a position when you go check
and checkmate
that will be too easy
it's gonna require a quiet move idea at
some point quiet no idea
yeah there's no restriction on the moves
here but just just to win it we're not
we need to do this in like two moves or
three moves so when you see a position
like this first you make a shortlist of
your candidate moves usually the move
that they look very natural here so
where are your candidate Nasir Quinn d31
and what's the second come they move
even more natural than Clinton aha
we need seven right it's you have a
feeling when you play enough you play
enough chess for a while you have a
feeling sometimes where which move is
the best
usually when you enter and get closer to
the king that's oftentimes
a good idea no exception here so that's
a personal check he cannot go to
backwards you know if he goes there it's
gonna be game over instantly checkmate
and it's made here as well okay
you don't want to do anything like that
it's gonna allow checks because once you
start checking you it's a wide-open
board you're not gonna have a place to
escape so you most likely will end in
the draw here don't allow him to check
you you want to be the first one who
checks now this next one is hard because
it's not as natural in fact it seems
like what are we doing you know we're
letting the kink escape you know no it's
got to be a check it's got to be a check
gotta be another check here
Queen g7 but then he is tips King at
five
correct correct
yes and if he goes back to age six
checkmate player that's why it doesn't
matter whichever yes now
strong move needed now
better
not then the most natural move here
Queen age 7 correct now he has to go to
f4 whenever you're forcing him to make
the only moves to getting closer these
two squares are not possible to go
because of night for twins the Quinn so
he has to go here and the most difficult
move of this position again always
remember series of checks but at some
point is going to be a quiet move that
sets up the winning idea
so you find this move it's gonna be over
immediately
mmm
no not Queenie seven because he goes
King f3 and he's gonna escape you don't
want to allow King f3 because King gave
treat then he escapes away can you have
three then his Queen will come it's
important to stop the King f3 move yeah
but then he escapes only three aha Queen
D three Queen D 3 and now let's try to
see what is the threat here when jittery
is a one threat let's say he moves the
Queen up somewhere so when J 3 is not
very effective then you have G 6 the
mate 96 is a mate here so you have
amazing trap 96 you cannot lab and he
doesn't have a check on d8 which is
important you cover that and you cannot
go back to e5 because of which idea nice
work is good Queen check is good and the
last idea if it takes your night queen
f1
okay you will acquaint so again let's go
back to the beginning so we start out
with a queen e7 check you found out
pretty quickly King has to go to g6 9f a
check not easiest move to find because
nine goes bit awkward position and again
Queen h7 again like most like Queen e6
are more not sure but you go Queen h7
here can I go to have six or a five so
it has to go here and then if a queen
the tree setting up the niger six me and
queen g3 as well alright okay well great
job everybody and we're gonna have
another lecture later on after this with
a very interesting topic so if you have
time please stay and thanks for coming
[Music]